diese unfassbar cremige Pastasoße kommt
aus dem Ofen erstmal gemüs schnibbeln
seit alles geschnibbelt ist geben wir es
auf dem Blech Blech ordentlich Olivenöl
drüber eine schöne Prise Salz und
Gewürze nach weal ich gebe ein bisschen
Oregano dazu jetzt geht das ganze in
Ofen ich gebe es unter ein umluftgrill
damit es richtig schön Farbe bekommt
nach 20 Minuten haben wir schon ein
bisschen Farbe dran ich wende das ganze
ein bisschen durch damit es schön
gleichmäßig wird aber es sieht schon
sehr gut aus jetzt gebe ich auch schon
mal meine Nudeln ins Wasser guckt euch
mal an wie schön das ganze hier geworden
ist so gebe ich jetzt einfach in mein
mixgefäß und jetzt ziehe ich das Ganze
einmal mit dem Mixstab durch jetzt ist
ein guter Zeitpunkt um noch ein bisschen
Chili reinzumachen damit das ein
bisschen mehr Bindung bekommt gebe ich
hier ein bisschen Creme fresch rein mit
Salz und Pfeffer abschmecken und fertig
ist die Soße jetzt stütte ich meine
Nudeln ab und zu den Nudeln geben wir
jetzt unsere
Soße hab ihr schon mal so eine cremige
Pasta gesehen ab auf den Teller damit
jetzt toppen wir das ganze mit ein
bisschen petasilie probieren wir das
Ganze durch diese Cremigkeit das ist so
unglaublich mama mia Bo du hast die
Röstaromen aus dem Ofen unglaublich gute
Pasta